grazie vito per la presentazione non
credo di meritare tutte le belle cose
che il vialetto grazie veramente per
l'invito
quando ho pensato cosa raccontarvi oggi
ho elaborato questo titolo inspiring
globalchange titolo un po forte forse in
realtà quello che ho visto oggi va
esattamente in questa direzione anzi
forse poca cosa
il titolo che io avevo in mente perché
se è vero come è vero che le piccole
storie fanno il cambiamento e fanno
l'evoluzione della nostra specie
oggi abbiamo visto qualcosa di davvero
straordinario l'ispirazione mi è
arrivata a questo a questo ragionamento
che voglio condividere con voi leggendo
il manifesto di ted e in particolare ho
trovato emozionante leggere parole come
queste cioè che l'obiettivo della
giornata odierna è avvicinare persone
idee sotto l'auspicio che questo evento
in un momento storico come questo possa
essere un fattore decisivo per ispirare
fiducia in un cambiamento profondo e
positivo credo che oggi come oggi
l'essere umano abbia bisogno di questo
cambiamento e abbia bisogno di
positività
più che mai quello cui siamo sottoposti
ogni giorno lo vedete l'ho sentito lo
sapete è una gran mole di notizie
negative
e siccome mi piace essere concreto ho
voluto provare a visivamente focalizzare
questo digitando su google trends che
già stato raccontato da un precedente
relatore quindi non so spiegarvi cos'è
lo sapete tutti è una sorta di focus
group digitale che dalla sensibilità di
quelle che sono le cose più ricercate in
rete ho provate a digitare due richieste
e ho chiesto al sistema dimmi quante
notizie negative danno i media e quante
notizie positive
e questo e output come vedete
costantemente siamo sovrastati da
notizie negative e questa non è una
sorpresa
lo step dopo che ho voluto fare ma
questo è quello che la gente vuole
sentirsi dire
e allora ho provato a cercare le parole
positive thinking e negativi thinking
e questo è la output la barra blu da la
mole di notizie invece positive che la
gente ricerca e la barra rossa dall'idea
delle notizie negative
quindi in sintesi una buona notizia cioè
la gente non vuole negatività vuole
positività perché questo è vissuto di
tutti nella positività si cresce bene si
vive meglio ancora una volta mi piace
dare concretezza a questo concetto non
so se conoscete masaru emoto è un
ricercatore giapponese che ha voluto
fisicamente verificare come
l'environment il mondo in cui noi ci
muoviamo c condizioni e cosa ha fatto ha
provato a cristallizzare delle gocce
d'acqua sottoponendole ad alcuni stimoli
ambientali che hanno prodotto formati di
cristalli diversi esempio ha provato a
cristallizzare dell'acqua mettendola in
provette e sulla provetta scrivendo la
parola grazie
e questa è la forma di cristallo che ha
ottenuto la fatto poi con la parola
felicità
guardate come cambia la forma da sempre
molto gradevole approvato poi con la
parola archivio e guardate che tipo di
output è arrivato ancora verità una
bella forma armonica ha poi provato a
lavorare anche con della musica e ha
sottoposto la cristallizzazione a una
colonna sonora ad esempio del ri meta
questo è il risultato
oppure a la quarantesima sinfonia di
mozart e questo è il risultato
perché questo è interessante perché se
voi pensate che noi siamo al 60 per
cento composti di acqua forse l'ambiente
qualche cosa su di noi influisce ma non
solo ma se è vero che noi siamo
influenzati dall'ambiente dalle parole
pensate che responsabilità abbiamo noi
stessi verso gli altri
noi stessi verso le persone con cui ci
relazioniamo e quindi quanto sia
importante un evento come questo che
produce valore produce positività ma non
solo per noi che siamo qui ma anche per
coloro che sono a distanza e qui vi
racconto velocemente una storia e forse
già conoscete di alcuni ricercatori
giapponesi
la storia della cosiddetta centesima
scimmia i quali hanno sostanzialmente
fatto della metà degli anni 50 delle
analisi etologiche su delle tribù di
cime che vivevano in isole del giappone
e le risultanze sono state quando c'è un
comportamento virtuoso che migliora la
qualità della vita viene immediatamente
imitato dal branco quindi tipicamente
questi scienziati lasciavano del cibo
delle patate sulla spiaggia e quando lei
mi hanno cominciato a lavarle quindi
togliere la sabbia e quindi approfittare
di questo cibo in maniera più gradevole
tutte le altre del gruppo hanno invitato
comportamento ma la cosa straordinaria è
che questo comportamento è stato imitato
anche da branchi che erano su altre
isole che non avevano il contatto con
queste scimmie come se ci fosse la
capacità a distanza di trasferire
informazione fantascienza
in effetti questa è stata molto
contestata questa prova scientifica ma
in realtà
in realtà il fatto di poter avere una
sorta di comunicazione a distanza
ce lo testimoniano
sostanzialmente due verità della fisica
quantistica
la prima è il fenomeno delle in tanti
mentre ci racconta come quando esistono
due particelle subatomiche che sono
correlate tra di loro quindi
hanno sostanzialmente una sorta di
gemellaggio e sono caratterizzate da
movimentazioni di spina opposti se
queste particelle sono distanziate si
cambia il movimento di una l'altra a
distanza replica l'osmosi che c'era
inizialmente quindi come se si
parlassero sostanzialmente del resto è
abbastanza accettato che i gemelli ad
esempio anche se su una distanza abbia
una sorta di forma di connessione sono
teorie in realtà che poi possiamo
applicare anche la nostra vita cioè
quante volte vi sarà capitato di pensare
a una persona che non vedete da tempo
per casualmente la incontrate secondo
recente diciamo scoperta che può diceva
un certo modo giustificarci se vogliamo
pensare che siamo connessi oltre quello
che si vede è la scoperta del bosone di
higgs che di fatto essendo una sorta di
ultimo l'ultima particella subatomica
che crea materia
ecco è la spiegazione teoricamente
scientifica al cosiddetto vuoto quantico
che non sarebbe un voto quantico
ma sarebbe sostanzialmente una sorta di
rete che tutto unisce e che tutto
diciamo di fatto tiene insieme a livello
di informazione quindi quindi in
sostanza noi abbiamo visto che tra di
noi esseri umani ci condizioniamo much
condizioniamo anche a distanza
non solo ma come se esistesse una sorta
di rete informativa che tutto connette e
che agevola questo passaggio di
informazione virtuosa
a me questo ricorda tanto il fenomeno
della rete quindi passando da qualcosa
di un pò onirico che quello che vi ho
raccontato fino ad ora a qualcosa invece
che la nostra vita vissuta quotidiana
pensate qui fondo come la rete sia
questa enorme stupenda straordinaria
forma di connessione visibile che ci
consente di diffondere
formazioni condividere crescere e
sostanzialmente trasferire know how tra
di noi quindi quindi perché è
fondamentale e importante quello che
stiamo vivendo oggi perché credo che
generatori di pensiero positivo e
condivisione di pensiero positivo sia un
qualche cosa che crea un valore che va
oltre il fatto di raccontarci qualcosa
veramente che aiuta a crescere tutti
quanti
e a questo punto giusto per coerenza se
la regia mi sostiene vi inviterei a
rileggere quel pezzo di manifesto di ted
con cui ho iniziato il mio speech perché
credo che possa ispirarvi ancora di più
e darvi ancor più senso del valore
aggiunto che c'è in quello che stiamo
vivendo oggi
avvicinare questo le idee sotto
l'auspicio che questo evento in un
momento storico come questo forse è un
fattore decisivo
per ispirare
in un cambiamento profondo e diffuso
credo che l'applauso va da tutti coloro
che hanno portato delle testimonianze
forte come quella che abbiamo
vi ringrazio